O you who have believed, do not consume usury, doubled and multiplied,
and I was
me
times for just
100 remember the propet peace be upon him
charity does not decree check the and
don Peace be upon him and the mercy of
God, we are here it
open
gu for anding
I was very long time ago so I know
what I have my
God willing, peace be upon him,
God willing, O
you who have believed, do not consume usury, doubled and multiplied, and
fear God that you may be successful. And fear the
Fire which has been prepared for the
disbelievers. And obey God and the Messenger that you may receive mercy. And hasten
to
forgiveness from your Lord and a Paradise as wide as the
heavens and earth, prepared for the righteous who
spend in prosperity and adversity and who restrain anger and who
pardon
people - and God loves the doers of good - and
who, when they commit an immorality or wrong
themselves, remember
God and seek
forgiveness for
their sins - and who can forgive sins except God? And who can forgive sins except God? And they did not
They persist in what they have done while they know.
Those will have their reward:
forgiveness from their Lord and gardens beneath which
rivers flow, wherein they will abide eternally. Excellent is the
reward of
the workers. God Almighty has spoken the truth.
Blessed is He who placed constellations in
the sky and
placed therein a lamp and a shining moon. And it is He who
made the night
and the day alternate for whoever
desires to
remember or desires gratitude. And
the servants of the Most Merciful are those who walk upon the earth easily,
and when the
ignorant address them [harshly], they say, "
Peace." And those who spend the night prostrating and standing before their Lord. And
those who say, "Our Lord, avert from me the punishment of
Hell. Indeed, its
punishment is ever-present; indeed,
it is an evil abode and residence." And those who,
when they
spend, are neither extravagant nor stingy, but hold a moderate course
between those extremes. And those who do not
invoke with God another deity,
nor
kill, nor kill the
soul which God has forbidden [to be killed], except by right, nor commit
adultery. And
whoever does that will meet a penalty. The punishment will be doubled for him
on the Day of
Resurrection, and he will abide therein disgraced,
except for those who repent and believe.  And
whoever does righteous deeds, Allah will replace
their evil deeds with
good deeds. And Allah is Forgiving and Merciful. And
whoever does
righteousness - indeed, he
repents to Allah with sincere repentance. And those who do
not bear false witness, and when they pass by idle talk, they
pass by with
dignity. And those who, when reminded of the verses of their Lord, do not
fall upon them deaf and blind. And
those who say, "Our Lord, grant
us from among
our wives
and offspring comfort to our eyes and
make us an example for the righteous." Those will be rewarded with a place of honor for what they
patiently endured, and they will be received therein with
greetings
and peace, abiding eternally therein. Excellent it is as a dwelling and as a place of
residence. Say, "My Lord would not care for you were it not for
your supplication. But you have denied [the truth]. So, there will be a punishment."
Allah has
spoken the truth. And Allah is the Most Merciful, the Most Compassionate. I'll be honest with you, he got a YouTube channel. Check out,
the only thing
giving me is a YouTube channel. I know, thinking he got a YouTube channel, and he does. Guys, please,
I'll be honest with you. I
absolutely recite the Quran. And he recites the Quran. He continues to be
beautiful, like, and
I'll be honest with you. For words, say like
that, he is beautiful.  brother follow
youtube if you want
to me number one fan me i love you i
love you